[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité la fin des
vacances de pâques partout en france
dans la loire gîtes et campings ont
accueilli de nombreux touristes locaux
une bonne nouvelle avant l'été nous dira
la rédaction de tl7 comment produire une
énergie propre et accessible un vosgien
a peut être trouvé la solution magique
et grâce à son hydroliennes 60
centimètres d'eau suffisent pour
répondre aux besoins énergétiques d'une
vingtaine de foyers les détails à suivre
avec vosges télévision plus de 200
chevaux sous le capot la nouvelle
voiture de sport de la gendarmerie
française se déploie sur toutes les
routes son objectif traquer les excès à
très grande vitesse des images du
journal la dépêche du midi à découvrir
dans un instant un site historique vieux
de cinq siècles et encore de nombreux
mystères à découvrir la citadelle de
doullens dans la somme fait l'objet de
fouilles archéologiques la rédaction de
wéo tva suivi des passionnés dans les
entrailles de ce site
les enfants de retour à l'école et les
parents au travail les vacances de
pâques sont terminées pour l'ensemble
des zones l'heure est déjà au bilan pour
les professionnels du secteur ils ont pu
profiter pour la première fois depuis
longtemps de la levée de toutes les
restrictions sanitaires visiblement les
touristes ont répondu présent exemple
dans la loire avec adrien bletterie de
la rédaction de tl7
réveiller tout en douceur pour cette
famille lyonnaise qui s'est installé
pour la nuit au camping de saint genest
malifaux en finition une bonne note
pouvoir prendre une douche
et déguster un petit peu les produits
locaux et oui car la semaine a été
sportive pour ces amoureux du vélo ils
ont pris leur deux roues pour effectuer
la via flux via un tracé qui relie le
rhône à la loire un dépaysement complet
qu'il ne regrette absolument pas on a
fait une rando vraiment superbe on
attendait la pluie qui n'est jamais
venue tant mieux pour nous sur les vélos
mais vraiment les paysages sont
magnifiques et c'était une belle saison
par rapport à la floraison vous l'aurez
compris le pilat est un immense terrain
de jeu pour les rois de la mais
ce n'est pas tout quelques kilomètres
plus loin au camping de saint sauveur en
rue on retrouve des marcheurs de tous
horizons la plupart inclus sont là pour
ça qu'un jour c'est en fait c'est le
chemin de saint-jacques-de-compostelle
en fait c'est un jour que ça un passage
york c'est une halte ici on a eu deux
personnes qui venaient du nord tous
trois ou quatre allemands qui sont lus
on a eu un beige
c'est un peu tout toutes générations et
puis tout toutes nationalités avec 6,25
réservations pendant ces quinze jours le
camping était rempli à 70% par moment
cette envie de retrouver la nature
l'office du tourisme des monts du pilat
le constate aussi les villes se vident
pendant les vacances scolaires ou de
gens qui sont vraiment en ville et qui
cherchent vraiment l'esprit d'être au
vert d'être dans la nature du coup donc
si ça ça se ressent depuis après april
sur l'année 2021 du coup ça s'est pas
mal ressenti way et ça continue et ça va
encore continuer pour les vacances d'été
beaucoup de réservations sont déjà
enregistrés dans les campings et dans
les gîtes du département voilà et d'ici
l'été et les longs trajets en voiture
les prix de l'essence auront peut être
baissé pour l'heure il côtoie toujours
des sommets une mauvaise nouvelle pour
les automobilistes mais aussi pour les
stations service indépendantes elles
peinent à conserver leur clientèle face
aux grands groupes plus souple sur les
prix certaines de ces stations ont même
dû fermer récemment à montpellier vous
allez le voir l'une d'elles se bat pour
maintenir sa présence dans son quartier
un reportage de winslow go pour vyas
occitanie le prix du carburant toujours
aussi élevé si les français bénéficient
depuis le 1er avril d'une remise de
l'état de 15 centimes par litre sur le
carburant il reste encore trop cher à
montpellier depuis longtemps ils sont
beaucoup à ne plus faire le plein de
leur véhicule pour le moment je n'ai que
trouver un rodez sens voilà j'essaie de
faire le mieux possible pour économiser
tout ça est trop cher l'essence ce
monsieur à ce moment et il faut qu'ils
baissent baisser les prix difficile à
faire pour les stations service
indépendantes depuis quelques jours en
france certains ont déjà baissé le
rideau ce gérant se bat pour ne pas en
arriver là mais son chiffre d'affaires
n'a cessé de chuter depuis trois ans une
perte de plus d'un million d'euros grâce
au chômage partiel serge a maintenu tous
ses emplois mais avec ce trou dans le
portefeuille il envisage le pire depuis
trois ans il n'a jamais bénéficié
d'aucune aide de l'état faute de remplir
les conditions à chaque fois on n'avait
pas assez de pertes il fallait je crois
perdre 50% du chiffre d'affaires donc
bien donc comme on était à 30 ou 35
donc on n'a pas eu encore d'être non je
sais pas ce que je vais je vais faire
l'année prochaine je sais pas du tout un
crève coeur pour les habitants du
quartier qui affectionnent ces stations
vieille de 40 ans et qui accepte de
rendre des petits services et vous
verserez si demain ces stations fermées
oh oui réellement elle y est depuis
presque 50 ans est une institution dans
le dans le quartier tout le monde vient
ici les clients fidèles qui parfois
n'hésite pas à payer plus cher chaque
fois me dépanne encore les sens
évidemment ici c'est un peu plus cher
mais je sais que c'est aussi difficile
pour lui beaucoup plus simple pour les
grosses d'écosociété donc je n'aurais je
privilégie et de vénétie en france le
nombre de stations services a diminué de
près de 73% en 40 ans
réduire le coût de l'énergie tout en
préservant l'environnement voilà une
équation difficile à résoudre qui
nécessite beaucoup d'innovations dans
les vosges vous allez le voir un
passionné de mécanique vient de
concevoir une hydrolienne d'un nouveau
genre celle ci n'a besoin que de 60
centimètres d'eau pour produire la
consommation quotidienne de dix à vingt
foyers une poisse technologique encore
en développement les précisions de
ludovic biya et de denis le ken de la
rédaction devos télévision
il suffit de quelques tours de clé plate
pour en desserrer le frein et remettre
ses pales en mouvement sur le canal
d'amenée d'une ancienne usine textile
des lois alain saint dizier peaufine son
hydroliennes passionné de mécanique cet
autodidacte installé à vagney s'est
lancé dans l'aventuré de l'énergie un
peu par hasard initialement pour
oxygéner les cours d'eau au départ
partait pour envoyer des muller dans
l'eau
et après on se dit qu'on aurait fait
jamais à
localiser ce principe donc on a apporté
génératrice pour pouvoir créer de
l'énergie et améliorer le les cours nous
cette hydrolienne produits de 40 à 60
kilowatts heure soit la consommation
quotidienne de dix à vingt foyers une
micro production donc peut-être mais une
unité facile à installer et sans aucun
impact ni sur la faune mais sur la flore
qui me faut 65 mètres minimum de hauteur
d'eau sur un couvent de 1 m
ce monde un mètre seconde c'est la
vitesse moyenne des cours d'eau vosgien
l'autre avantage de cette hydrolienne
d'une dizaine de tonnes c'est son
installation rapide à l'aide d'une grue
en trois heures seulement quant au
principe de production d'électricité cie
les simples en apparence sa mise en
pratique est beaucoup plus complexe pour
faire tourner la génératrice il s'agit
de passer de 6 tours minute à 400 le
secret dans les boîtiers de
transformation du mans poussé en
mouvement rotatif
aujourd'hui les peuples un secret donc
bien gardé de multiplicateurs dissimulée
sous cette bâche que nous n'avons pas
été autorisés à filmer l'ensemble est
d'ailleurs sous vidéo surveillance car
de multiples études sont toujours en
cours d'un second prototype va être
construit dans les prochaines semaines
avec des améliorations du procédé
l'amélioration du design également et
l'idée c'est une commercialisation d'ici
la fin de l'année le projet a déjà coûté
quatre cent mille euros à ses
concepteurs objectif en produire une
dizaine l'année prochaine
jean christophe cambadélis était
l'invité jeudi dernier de l'émission
face aux territoires sur tv5 monde
l'ancien premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste est notamment revenu sur les
tractations à gauche pour les élections
législatives
écoutez ce qu'il a dit alors moi je suis
sur une position de refondation de la
gauche passer de la bouche de
gouvernement avaient été contactés par
emmanuel macron où ses équipes vont donc
sûr que non je ne suis pas dans la
majorité présidentielle
et je ne suis pas dans l'opposition
mélenchonistes je suis dans l'idée qu'il
y a un chemin
populaire
social-démocrate ouvert
un réformiste de gauche
transformant la société de manière
responsable et c'est celui du parti
socialiste mais pour cela il faut
totalement se refonder voilà l émission
face aux territoires avec jean
christophe cambadélis est à voir ou
revoir sur les sites internet des
partenaires de l'émission ouest france
nice matin et vingt minutes tout à fait
autre chose dans l'actualité la vie à la
campagne n'est pas toujours aussi
paisible que l'imaginent c'est le
message en tout cas que porte le maire
d'une petite commune de la sarthe au
travers d'une campagne d'affichage chant
de coq bout et du clocher passage des
camions et des tracteurs autant de
nuisances sonores habituelle dans les
zones rurales qui suscitent parfois la
colère des habitants fraîchement
débarqué à la campagne reportage
d'anthony python pour la chaîne lmtv
sarthe
avis aux nouveaux habitants de noyen sur
sarthe à la campagne aussi il y à du
bruit le maire lance l'alertent à tous
ceux qui souhaitent s'installer dans sa
commune et le message est on ne peut
plus claire plus des habitants qui
semble émouvoir en fait en me demandant
de réduire aussi la sonnerie des cloches
voilà et pour les coques j'ai eu
plusieurs courriers parce qu'il fallait
que j'intervienne pour faire supprimer
l'école donc c'est vrai que si on veut
pas voir de camions si on veut pas avoir
de tracteurs ici on veut pas entendre le
coq chante et faut mieux aller voir plus
loin des panneaux comme celui ci sont
installés à toutes les entrées du
village
objectif répondre aux plaintes des
nouveaux habitants arrivés ces derniers
mois jean-yves a même lancé une pétition
il ya le bruit de camions point barre
camions qui passent d'une manière
intempestive
imaginez un camion qui passe devant
votre fenêtre à deux mètres de votre
fenêtre de la cuisine par exemple c'est
pas légitime du tout de transformer le
centre ville de noyen en autoroute pour
camions quoi
ce qui poserait donc le plus problème
aux néo ruraux c'est le passage des
camions et le vrombissement des
tracteurs sébastien agriculteurs de
noyen averti la campagne n'est pas
toujours paisible mais on n'a pas le
choix faut bien mon travail donc
on est obligé de passer la commune c'est
la commune étant
en sens unique donc les camions ou les
tracteurs de toujours passer dans la
même rue dans le village la campagne
d'affichage du maire fait beaucoup
parler et tout le monde n'y est pas
favorable pour les nouveaux arrivants
c'est pas tellement c'est pas tellement
sympa je trouve que c'est
voilà moi ça m'a un peu choqué quoi
qu'il en soit les nouveaux habitants
devront s'habituer au bruit et aux
odeurs ou repartir depuis un an le droit
protège ce patrimoine sensorielle des
campagnes
elle aussi fait du bruit la nouvelle
voiture de sport de la gendarmerie
l'alpine a110 le bolide de ultra
performant peut atteindre les 100 km/h
en 5 secondes seulement sa principale
mission chasser les excès de vitesse les
plus importants en tout 26 voitures de
sport de ce type ont été livrée à la
gendarmerie en france ces derniers mois
notamment vous allez le voir en
haute-garonne images et interviews
recueillies par clément gaci pour notre
partenaire sur place de la dépêche du
midi mission principale c'est tout ce
qui est excès de vitesse à partir de 40
km heure donc aujourd'hui on voit bien
que les
le marché de l'automobile a évolué donc
on se devait également d'évoluer avec
des machines plus récente va nous
permettre de lutter principalement sur
les
les phases de départ en vacances sur les
gros excès vitesse sur le réseau
autoroutier route et de la haute garonne
comment faire face aux risques naturels
quand on travaille dans un musée pendant
trois jours une vingtaine de
professionnels en provenance de
martinique de guadeloupe ou de la
métropole se sont réunis à fort de
france pour une formation pratique sur
ce sujet l'objectif c'est les aider à se
préparer en cas de catastrophe naturelle
à sauver un maximum de oeuvres d'art
comme vous le voyez sur ces images de la
rédaction martiniquaise de via à tv les
participants ont notamment assisté à des
ateliers avec la croix rouge et les
pompiers
sans transition dans ce journal parlons
de langues étrangères en haute savoie il
n'est plus essentiel de partir à
l'étranger pour améliorer son niveau
d'anglais une entreprise locale propose
aux enfants et aux adultes des séjours
linguistiques dans des familles
anglophones installés en france l'idée
originale séduit de plus en plus de
monde comme l'a constaté victoria lopes
2,8 mon blanc qui a travaillé son accent
british poursuivre le séjour d'un jeune
collégien regardez
les tiennent à 14 ans il est originaire
de paris et il a choisi de partir en
séjour linguistique pour améliorer son
niveau d'anglais je comprends l'anglais
à l'oral de parler simple flecher pour
prendre confiance et faire des progrès
il n'est pas en angleterre mais à gex
dans l'ain chére basto il passe une
semaine en immersion avec chaque jour
une heure de leçon dispensée par max
l'aîné de la famille on finit souvent
par part en apprendre plus anglais juste
dans les conversations quand on a d'un
jour à l'autre ou pas forcément même
dans les cours mais c'est aussi faire
ses cours d'une heure par jour pour un
peu regardé le vocabulaire qui
manqueraient ou des programmeurs les
parents de max emma hill son mari
johnattan vivent en france depuis 19 ans
leurs quatre enfants sont complètement
bilingue est à la maison il parle
uniquement en anglais il environ quatre
ans les bastons ont décidé de devenir
famille d'accueil
ils ne sont pas très loin de chez eux
mais ils ont une vraie expérience
anglaise dans une maison d'anglais et
nous ne parle qu'anglais la maison mais
ils ont l'avantagé de savoir quand une
famille française les enfants sont
bilingues et doit s'il ya un problème
nous pouvons communiquer en français
proposer des séjours linguistiques pour
des jeunes ou des adultes sans changer
de pays c'est l'idée de bettina gare
bergoglio et c'est sur les bords du lac
d'annecy où elle réside que le concept
est ni j'ai une maman française un pape
allemand et je suis né aux états unis et
je remarquais que ma maman recevait tout
le temps plein de demandes pour trouver
des familles d'accueil aux états unis et
puis quand j'ai grandi j'ai eu mes
enfants que j'ai mis à l'école dans mon
village et dans mon village à les
plaindre anglais avec qui on interagit
c'est et ça fait un peu un clic entre ce
ces demandes de familles d'accueil et
tous ces anglais avec qui qui habitait à
côté de chez nous la crise du coc
vidailhan complexifier l'organisation de
voyages à l'étranger l'offre de my
english family séduit de plus en plus de
monde créée en 2015 l'entreprise compte
aujourd'hui plus de 180 familles hôtes
partout en france
c'est la star du printemps de retour sur
nos marchés la saison de la fraise a
débuté et les prix varient selon la
provenance pour éviter les mauvaises
surprises il est possible de se fier au
label rouge un gage de qualité au cahier
des charges très strict dans le
lot-et-garonne vous allez le voir 86
producteurs et productrices jouissent de
ce label tv7 a rencontré l'une d'entre
elles sous ses serres à l'heure de la
récolte à sujet divan branchies
un rouge écarlate synonyme d'une saveur
optimale ces fraises s'il vise un outil
les produits depuis bientôt 20 ans est
ici chaque variété et la belle rouge
d'un gariguette il ya une scie fleurette
charlotte est la dernière à l'as et
d'anglars fameuse mariette taux de sucre
coloration et même emballage quand une
fraise est labellisé rien n'est laissé
au hasard et si l'une des 80 étapes de
production n'est pas respectée en
direction la catégorie une larme prenait
4 comme ça où tous les frais sont à
maturité top d'envahir pas de déception
c'est sur l'a27 mercato nous avons
plusieurs types de plusieurs niveaux de
maturité
est donc là il rappelait tout est
différent mais pour en arriver là il a
fallu saddam dise s'il n'y a aucun moyen
de lutter contre les mauvaises herbes
bien faire attention ne pas arracher le
fraisier et prendre à la racine à les
produits chimiques formellement
interdits ont des alternatives comme ces
plaques adhésives contre les insectes ou
des sachets contre les ravageurs donc
l'intérêt c'est de les laisser au milieu
de la plante il est mis sur ce qu'il
sorte et nice et se nourrissent donc de
tout ce qu'écrit un petit sachet tout de
même 6 à 10 fois plus cher qu'un
traitement chimique mais amortie pour
l'instant par le bénéfice du label rouge
on a à peu près 2 euros 2 euros à deux
autres haltes de 0,52 plus d'admiration
lait fraise label rouge sont ensuite
vendus en grande distribution près de
600 euros le kilo quand la fraise
standard avoisine les 9 euros dans le
lot et garonne sur les dix-sept mille
tonnes de fraises produites cette année
environ 600 tonnes son label rouge
voilà et des produits de saison et de
qualité sont également accessibles du
côté de monaco des élèves de la
principauté viennent de participer à un
programme en vue d'élaborer cinq menus
spéciaux issus de la consommation
durable cette opération de
sensibilisation été notamment menée par
le chef étoilé marcel ravin écoutez le
au micro de vanessa de 6 de la rédaction
de monaco à chaud
lafleur a une particularité c'est que ça
avoue mais c'est un goût marincin
bouillot des je crois que il faut garder
son âme d'enfant pour pouvoir comprendre
les enfants le fait de venir et de
d'être complètement immergé et non on
voit maintenant leur parle et je suis
convaincu qu'ils sont encore plus
attentifs et je sais pas si je pourrai
le faire tous les jours je vous mets
passer un peu de temps avec les enfants
comme ça et de faire profiter de notre
connaissance et et de les voir les yeux
pétillants comme ça c'est incroyable et
c'est génial et pour être tout à fait
précis sachez que ces menus durable
concocté par les enfants seront proposés
dans toutes les cantines scolaires de la
principauté le 17 juin prochain restons
à monaco où depuis 61 ans est organisé
un festival dédié à la télévision studio
chaîne et plateformes digitales se
retrouvent chaque année pour des
projections des rencontres avec les
stars du petit écran les organisateurs
du festival de télévision de monte carlo
ont dévoilé il ya quelques jours à paris
la programmation de cette édition 2022
riche en événements vous allez le voir
regardez ce sujet de christophe rigaud
un tapis rouge des stars et des
programmes venus du monde entier le
festival de télévision de monte carlo
est de retour après une 60e édition très
franco française pour cause de crise
sanitaire cette année le festival
redevient internationale cette année on
peut dire c'est reparti comme en 14 avec
une sélection internationale pour la
compétition avec trois ou quatre
programmes à l'avant-première mondiale
l'ouverture du festival avec une
avant-première mondiale a slight avec
vraiment une série d'actualités vous
verrez vous verrez la série c'est
vraiment très très très intéressant
le retour des américains un programme
très riche pour le public puisque vous
savez que le public à une partie à une
part très importante pour notre festival
cette année une vingtaine de programmes
seront en compétition en fictions
documentaires ou actualité avec comme
président du jury l'acteur et producteur
neal mcdonough 9 et pour animer la
cérémonie des nymphes d'or le festival a
fait appel aux magiciens et humoriste
eric antoine et à la miss france 2000 21
amandine petit une remise de prix par
définition c'est extrêmement mécanique
et c'est souvent assez rébarbatif donc
mon team engagé grosse erreur de leur
part
et c'est toute l'idée ça va être de un
joaillier délire voilà je suis trublion
du coin voilà j'habitais à
aix-en-provence si on lit le mec est pas
loin via
voilà moi pour le coup je me pose encore
la question de pourquoi parce que je ne
parle ni anglais c'est la première fois
que je présente ce genre de choses mais
pour le coup se retrouver de l'autre
côté cette fois ci sur scène je mets ça
hyper intéressant et je pense que c'est
une expérience qui aiment faire grandir
mais de dingue le festival de télévision
de monte carlo se tiendra du 17 au 21
juin à monaco avec des conférences sur
les coulisses des séries des rencontres
avec les stars des projections mais
surtout le festival gratuit et ouvert au
public
du luxe monégasque à l'élégance de
versailles dans ce grand jt l'un des
hôtels les plus emblématiques de la
ville royale le trianon palace est
dirigé par un nouveau directeur ou
plutôt une directrice une première dans
l'histoire de ce palace construit en
1910 stéphanie rambo originaire du
royaume uni est évidemment heureuse de
sa nouvelle prise de fonction comme elle
l'a expliqué à justine brasier
journaliste de tv 78 dans les yvelines
c'est un hôtel personnellement pour
laquelle je suis très attaché ça fait
quelques années que je travaille avec
hilton et j'ai vu un petit peu cette
source elle dans le contexte mon travail
d'avants et c'était toujours l'hôtel qui
m'a passionné donc évidemment très fier
c'est beaucoup de sens de détail et
quelque part c'est aussi un plaisir
beaucoup plus à l'âge est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus longue donc c'est vraiment
de se mettre dans les suceurs de nos
clients par rapport à ses attentes ses
besoins
c'est un site historique de 5 siècles
encore rempli de secrets la citadelle de
doullens dans la somme fait l'objet de
nouvelles fouilles archéologiques depuis
la fin du mois d'avril objectif en
apprendre un peu plus sur le site et son
évolution à travers le temps entre
rempart contre les envahisseurs espagnol
ou prison pour les femmes plongez dans
les souterrains de la citadelle avec
jérémy houbron de web tv la chaîne de la
voix du nord
c'est une muraille degré vieille de plus
de cinq siècles pourtant si la citadelle
de doullens est habitué à recevoir du
public elle est bien loin d'avoir révélé
tous ses secrets dans ses entrailles une
équipe d'archéologues combien faire la
lumière sur un peu de son histoire
à pouvoir commencer à faire le relevé
papier sephora et étudiantes dans un des
bastions de l'édifice elle mesure
photographie schématise une canonnière
etc ferrures on a de bons sur les côtés
et en os on a une attache avec un anneau
ce qui peut on peut supposer que la
porte qui permettait de fermer la
canonnière se ferme et horizontalement
et qu'il y avait un verrou placé
verticalement pour fermer la canonnière
et protéger les et les défenses être
construite en 15/100 34 sous le règne de
françois 1er pour défendre le royaume
contre les espagnols la citadelle de
doullens subi au fil des siècles bien
des modifications
d'abord prison elle devient hôpital
militaire puis zen ex du camp de
buchenwald sous l'occupation nazie bref
elle en a vu cette citadelle si bien
qu'aujourd'hui il devient difficile de
dater chaque aménagement ça devrait nous
permet de repérer éventuellement
différentes typologies de fermeture et
peut-être de dater différents moments de
réaménagement des bastions des
réaménagements qu'il faut sonder
observer et même immortalisé aux confins
de ce dédale souterrain une autre équipe
est au travail théo prépare un diplôme
d'ingénieur topographe équipé d'un
scanner ils parcourent les contremine de
l'édifice 1400 mètres de galeries qu'il
pourra ensuite modélisé en trois
dimensions le principe donc c'est de
positionner des scanners et puis deux
qui vont mesurer des points et mis au
point à la seconde et puis après
d'assembler tous ces scanners pour
pouvoir avoir un chemin avec tout
l'ensemble des données qu on a mesuré un
objet d'étude sur près de 30 hectares
qui permettra de mieux comprendre
l'histoire du site mais également de le
sécuriser il y a énormément de cheminée
qu'on appelle des évents dans les
contremine dont certaines on ne sait pas
les localiser en surface donc grâce au
travail de l'imsa ce travail souterrain
eh bien on va pouvoir localiser les
points qui pourraient être susceptibles
d'être dangereux et de les sécuriser
d'ici l'année prochaine les relevés 3d
serviront à l'élaboration d'une visite
virtuelle des souterrains de la
citadelle pour rendre visible une
histoire
perceptible à nos yeux
une belle histoire pour terminer cette
édition celle d'une chorale constituée
d'amateurs dans l'aube la troupe c'est
son nom connaît un succès étonnant
depuis quelques années ces passionnés de
chant multiplie les représentations un
peu partout en france et se produiront
notamment ce mois ci dans la mythique
salle du palais des glaces à paris une
fierté bien sûr pour ses 37 amateurs
propos recueillis par willy briard du
journal l'est éclair notre partenaire
sur place
la chance d'avoir fait des rencontres
extraordinaires depuis quatre ans où on
a joué au théâtre antique d'orange
avec les musiciens de goldman sur un
projet sur goldman a fait des nuits de
champagne de marques avoine
voilà et cesser ces rencontres là qui
font grandir aussi le groupe à travers
ces projets et du coup on a des
ambitions on dirait mais toujours avec
le plaisir et c'est un groupe amateur
c'est vraiment très important de le
signaler bravo à eux et bonne chance
évidemment pour leur aventure parisienne
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt les
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]